souvenez vous souvenez vous quand vous
étiez hélène vous souvenez vous après
une mauvaise note ou à devoir juger
plutôt médiocre avoir le sentiment que
vous pouviez douter de votre
intelligence vous souvenez vous avoir dû
confronter le regard de quelqu'un qui
pouvait m'évaluer cette intelligence
avez vous le souvenir d'avoir aller
d'avoir voulu aller beaucoup plus loin
que la connaissance que vous aviez des
choses d'être face à un obstacle et vous
être utile
non c'est pas pour moi faut pas être
assez intelligent et que ça pourrait
durer toute la vie
qu'est ce que l'intelligence les
neurosciences aujourd'hui nous
apprennent énormément de choses sur
l'avant sur la connaissance du cerveau
même si nous avons encore beaucoup à
apprendre et étonnamment nous restons
plutôt sourd et aveugle par rapport aux
avancées des neurosciences par rapport
au développement du cerveau de
l'intelligence j'ai connu un petit
garçon ce petit garçon est né avec une
souffrance ce talent ou partie de son
cerveau a été détruite
et lorsqu'il est né ses parents ou
entendu cette chose assez terrible qu'on
disait avant il ya quelques années les
que peut-être on dit encore aujourd'hui
ils ont entendu que cet enfant était un
enfant légumes et que peut-être ils
allaient se développer comme un légume
ses parents ont ramené ce bébé à la
maison et l'ont aimée comme leurs deux
autres petits garçons ce petit garçon
est allé à l'école et il a pris les
choses avec il avait besoin de temps
sans doute de beaucoup plus de temps
pour comprendre ce que les autres
apprenez plutôt rapidement alors il a
souffert psychologiquement à cause du
regard que l'on portait sur lui sur son
handicap d'un enfant imc infirme moteur
cérébral il est en fauteuil roulant il a
souffert physiquement ou aussi aux jeux
parce que il a fallu l'opérer
souffrez l'atrophié musculaire mais il
s'est battu il s'est battu longtemps il
a réussi à passer son bac
florent est aujourd'hui titulaire d'une
licence il parfaitement autonome
il ya un travail d'un jeune homme
heureux aujourd'hui
est ce que ce petit bonhomme aurait pu
s'en sortir aussi bien s'il n'avait pas
eu le soutien de ses parents de ses
soignants deux de ses enseignants c'est
une question qui restera sans réponse
aujourd'hui
j'ai connu une petite fille aussi cette
petite fille ne comprenait pas que les
mots avaient du sens et plus les mots
les uns après les autres former des
phrases et que ces phrases déterminer le
monde dans lequel elle vivait et
pouvez-vous expliquer le monde dans
lequel elle vivait quand j'étais jeune
cognitivistes alors impunité vie c'est
quelqu'un qui travaille sur le cerveau
en situation d'apprentissage
c'est quelqu'un qui va travailler sur la
mémoire sur le langage ou sur
l'attention sur les fonctions qui vont
permettre à la personne d'apprendre et
donc quand j'étais jeune cognitivistes
je me disais que les enfants dont
j'avais la charge avait de très belles
potentialités d'avenir mais je ne savais
pas à l'époque les neurosciences aller
nous éclairer sur un concept extrêmement
important extraordinaire que l'on
appelle la plasticité cérébrale
je vais vous expliquer la plasticité
cérébrale
c'est la capacité pour le cerveau à se
développer tout au long de la vie parce
qu'il va devoir s'adapter à son
environnement et à l'expérience
le cerveau est capable de modifier ses
réseaux de neurones
le cerveau est capable de modifier son
architecture cérébrale parce qu'il va
devoir s'adapter tout au long de la vie
à l'environnement et aux expériences
notre cerveau est capable de se modifier
tout au long de la vie et il le fera
très très bien
finalement c'est quoi être intelligent
alors je vous poserai bien la question
est ce que vous pouvez prendre deux
trois secondes en vous pour répondre à
cette question c'est quoi être
intelligent est ce que c'est être
capable de s'adapter
est ce que c'est être bon en
mathématiques
est ce que c'est être capable de
travailler avec les autres est-ce que
c'est faire preuve de créativité sans
doute qu'il ya autant de réponses qu'il
y a de personnes ici nous avons tous
notre petite idée sur le sujet
on va faire tout simple alfred binet qui
était le père de l'échelle métriques qui
va devenir par la suite notre cuit
disait avec beaucoup d'humour
c'est tout simple l'intelligence est ce
que mesure mon test et pourtant
est-ce que nous sommes si loin de cette
boutade il ya peut-être dans cette salle
l'un deux petits garçons et deux
petites-filles devenu grand s'ils ont
une impression qui n'était pas très bon
pour l'école qui n'était pas très
intelligent parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
les codes de l'école parce qu'il n'avait
pas le langage de l'école où la culture
de l'école lorsqu'on ne leur avait pas
appris à prendre parce qu'ils étaient
dyslexiques ou dyscalculiques parce
qu'on leur a dit cette chose terrible
que l'intelligence et être inné et que
par voie de conséquence la stupidité les
thèmes si peut-être à cause d'une bonne
fée ou d'une sorcière présentes autour
de leur berceau de jour de leur
naissance
j'ai d'ailleurs une question pour vous
pourquoi est-ce que n'expliquons pas aux
enfants ce qu'est intelligence pourquoi
est ce qu'on ne leur explique pas que
l'intelligent ne va pas être fixes tout
au long de la vie qu'elle va évoluer
tout au long de la vie tous les enfants
sont capables de comprendre ce que
albert jacquard généticien français nous
disaient l'intelligence n'est pas
quelque chose que l'on reçoit c'est
quelque chose que l'on construit tout au
long de la vie ceux qui voudraient nous
faire croire que tout se joue avant 6
ans nous mentent
ce n'est pas vrai ceux qui voudraient
nous faire part aussi que l'intelligence
va rester fixe tout au long de la vie
nous mentent aussi tous les enfants vont
évoluer tout au long de la vie parce que
c'est avant tout une réalité biologique
alors évidemment votre cerveau et dans
un corps qui a lui-même un passé un
présent un futur il a une structure
génétique qui lui est propre qui n'est
pas figée il est unique
quelqu'un me demandait il n'y a pas si
longtemps
si l'école favorisait la modifier
habilités de l'intelligence évidemment
que l'épaule participe à la modifier
habilités de l'intelligence sans doute
même que c'est sa fonction première qui
devrait être sa fonction première
évidemment pour apprendre bien un enfant
va gérer la connaissance bien sûr de la
nouvelle connaissance très important
parce que la nouvelle connaissance va
venir se confronter à de la connaissance
de l'enfant a déjà et qui est forcément
erronée et de cette confrontation de
connaissances va cela va donner
naissance à une nouvelle connaissance
est très importante pour la modification
de notre cerveau mais pour pouvoir
apprendre bien l'enfant a aussi besoin
de travailler avec théo de collaborer
avec les autres on apprend énormément d
autres pour apprendre bien l'enfant doit
aussi être motivé ce fameux mot mais je
tiens à préciser les choses
suite la motivation est avant tout un
facteur biologique pour apprendre bien
un enfant a aussi besoin de nouveauté le
cerveau est extrêmement excité par la
nouveauté les enfants le savent bien
mais bon tout ça ce sont des
considérations pédagogiques pour
apprendre bien un enfant a surtout
besoin d'être regardée c'est important
que l'enfant puisse être regardé et que
l'enfant soit sûr que les adultes qui
vont l'accompagner sur le chemin de la
vie croit en son et du kabylité en son
intelligence sans l'ombre d'un doute
c'est très important parce que ce regard
va déposer en lui qu'il eut atteint s'il
tiendra chaud au coeur de l'aide tout la
vie tu es capable
un regard construit autant qu'il détruit
est-ce qu'on pourrait d'ailleurs faire
l'hypothèse qu'un regard plutôt
malveillants puisse porter atteinte au
système cognitif de l'enfant
je crois qu'on peut en faire
d'hypothèses aucun enfant ne peut défier
le regard de l'adulte qui lui laisserait
croire qu'il n'est pas capable
un enfant ne devrait pas entendre
parfois dès son plus jeune âge en
primaire que bam vous les études
supérieures ça va pas être pour lui
parce que déjà ses parents ma foi avant
lui ne s'en était pas si bien sorti que
ça aucun enfant de vent devraient
entendre dès le primaire que il n'a pas
le bon qi ou qu'il a atteint ses limites
y a rien de pire à entendre pour
quelqu'un d'autant plus si est un enfant
qu'il a atteint ses limites
est ce qu'il y a derrière la limite
aucun enfant ne peut défier le regard de
l'adulte parce que pour pouvoir survivre
l'enfant va se soumettre regarde n'a pas
de choix il n'a pas la force
psychologique pour pouvoir défier le
regard en tout cas moi en 25 ans de
carrière je n'ai je n'ai jamais vu
d'enfants capable de défier le regard de
l'adulte
nous pensons toujours qu'il ya des
enfants plus ou moins intelligent sur
quels critères sur des critères très
ancestraux nous pensons toujours et en
voie de conséquence que du coup il ya
des enfants qui pourraient être plus ou
moins doués pour l'école nous continuons
à expliquer la difficulté scolaire ars
qu'on appelle parfois le déterminisme
scolaire le déterminisme social avec
l'idée que le déterminisme social ma foi
n'est pas de si différent que
déterminisme naturel il ya évidemment
des enfants qui ont des difficultés
sociales qui ne favorise pas les
apprentissages
mais ce raccourci entre déterminisme
social et le déterminisme cognitif est
un petit peu rapide le cui ans ferme
le cui est un indicateur statistique qui
n'a aucune réalité biologique
aujourd'hui les scientifiques les plus
humbles ne s'engage pas sur le chemin de
la définition de l'intelligence
parce que ça pose un problème éthique on
ne peut pas catégoriser les gens en
fonction de leur intelligence
l'intelligence est bien trop vaste avec
tous les sauveteurs planète pour pouvoir
réduire l'intelligence en une définition
la définition ne peut pas être ce que
l'on définit ozon sortir de ce qui fige
et ozone sortir de ce qui catégorise est
ce que l'on peut imaginer une école qui
ne catégories seraient pas les enfants à
cause de leurs difficultés mais qui
pourrait accueillir les enfants parce
qu'ils ont des défis à relever
la difficulté écrasant que défi quant à
lui est beaucoup plus dynamique ne pas
enfermer les enfants dans un
déterminisme biologique est extrêmement
porteur expliquer aux enfants comment on
construit son intelligence engage la
responsabilité éthique d'un pays par
rapport à son système scolaire ne pas
enfermer l'enfant dans un déterminisme
et ce qui a le plus porteur pour que ces
enfants qui vont devenir des hommes et
les femmes puissent prendre le chemin de
lorsque l'arrêté de leur vie en gardant
la tête haute
la petite fille qui ne comprenaient pas
que les mots avaient un sens vous
remercie beaucoup de l'avoir écouté